Tan tan centrados estaban en que el enemigo era España,
no que todas las burguesías que construían esa ficción
em sobre el independentismo.
Estas burguesías del trespercent
estaban también muy empeñados en que no,
no entrara, por ejemplo,
inmigración
hispana a Cataluña porque era españolizante,
no, porque, y eso, y el enemigo era España. Y entonces
priorizaron
ya, ¿eh? En la época de Puyol, a la inmigración marroquí.
Y ese, al final, es el precedente
de que no sé si algún día hablaremos de 1 república
catalana,
pero que desde luego que lo que está probablemente
más cerca es el emirato árabe de Cataluña, ¿no?
Y igual acaba siendo 1 república islámica
o 1 república islámica.
El caso es que prefectura marroquí,
prefectura marroquí también,
¿cual cualquiera de sus vertientes no?
Pero que en cualquier caso yo creo que volvemos
al debate inicial,
que creo que VA a ser crucial y que VA a trufar ese
ese cambio sociocultural y demográfico de Cataluña,
que que lo decimos